tout au long de la semaine nous allons
revenir sur le festival de cannes en
partenariat avec radio sensations la
station a dépêché sur place des
journalistes de sa rédaction afin de
suivre l'actualité des yvelinois présent
pour téléfilm nicolas kirillovitch nous
propose aujourd'hui une rencontre avec
la comédienne elena soubeyrand elle est
née à saint germain en laye où elle a
résidé pendant neuf ans elle a été
sélectionnée dans le cadre de
l'opération de l'adami talents cannes
qui mettent en avant des jeunes espoirs
du cinéma français
elena s'oublieront retenez bien ce nom
cette jeune comédienne originaire des
yvelines entre dans la lumière après
plusieurs rôles au théâtre à la
télévision et au cinéma elle a été
retenue cette année dans le cadre de
l'opération talents cannes organisé par
l'association artistique de l'adami la
sélection a été drastique comme nous
l'expliquent lna on s'inscrit sur le
site à damien n'était mille je crois et
dans les mille îles ont sélectionné une
centaine et dans les sens il faisait les
auditions chaque réalisateur voyez donc
moi j'ai passé pour plusieurs
réalisateurs et après et choisissez
leurs comédiens qu'on était 22 à la fin
donc voilà une vraie audition avec des
call back on retourne séance de travail
tout ça c'est très chouette l'opération
talents cannes de l'adami fête cette
année ses 20 ans la réalisation des
courts métrages a été confiée à des
comédiens des promotions antérieures
elena soubeyrand a ainsi tourné sous la
direction dorati qu'à elle-même
sélectionnés en 1994 une collaboration
enrichissante elle a des idées très
claires elles fonctionnent vraiment par
image par des images de films d'acteurs
d'intensité à la des couleurs très
précises donc c'est très agréable de
travailler avec elle elle sait vraiment
où elle va ce film réalisé par aure
atika donc et dans lequel joue elena
soubeyrand c on ne badine pas avec
rosette une troupe de théâtre jeux
plutôt étrange
regardez comme son nom l indique s'est
inspiré de ne badine pas avec l'amour et
c'est une jeune actrice qui remplace au
pied levé une actrice dans une pièce qui
tourne déjà beaucoup et elle va se
retrouver dans un très beau théâtre et
il est très beau costume et chez des
gens qui sont pas très sympathique
c'était quoi ça berisha sont deux pièces
le plus touché ainsi l'eau sinon quoi tu
m'as proche parent et qui vont lui faire
vivre un moment vraiment assez
surréaliste et cafés de beaux discours
n'est ce pas gageons qu'il a promis de
l'épouser
comment savez vous qu importe comment je
laissais crois-tu à ses promesses
rosette
comment n'y croyais pas il me tromperais
donc pourquoi pas
verdict on déposera pas un enfant ces
courts métrages de l'adami ont été
présentés ce lundi au palais des
festivals
autre temps fort de la journée pour les
jeunes espoirs du cinéma la montée des
marches un moment très attendu et
inoubliable forcément pour elena
soubeyrand et ses camarades comédiens
sous le feu des projecteurs et sous les
flashes des photographes pendant
quelques instants
et quand on entende notre nom sur ce
grand tapis et conques est tellement
mythique avec ce tapis rouge le festival
de cannes marca en grand on le voit
depuis tout petit c'est vraiment un truc
on se dit c'est d'essayer là je la chute
devant juger le tgv pour le tapis sous
les pieds ça est pas prêt à cette très
forte
si vous voulez découvrir les stars de
demain après paris première et hier soir
c'est france 4 qui diffusera à leur
court métrage demain à partir de 23h40
portage de radio sensations qui
proposera sur son antenne une émission
spéciale un zeste d'infos depuis le
festival ce dimanche 26 mai à partir de
19h avec et des portraits et des
rencontres de comédiens réalisateurs du
département et puis un point sur la
production cinématographique en ile de
france